[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie they dropped a
trailer for frozen - and it looks like
they're going full avatar the last
airbender with a whole bunch of
different powers based on different
elements so I'll try to explain what's
going on during this will do a new round
- that Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite frozen moment on the video
the whole thing with this trailer that
was confusing people this morning is
there's no dialogue so of course you
have no context for what's going on but
they have released some story details so
I'll explain what the story is and
there's a lot of Easter eggs and clues
as to what's going on with the
characters in the footage that they gave
us so one biggest thing they go to a
completely different place it doesn't
take place in the wintery location of
arendelle they're going somewhere where
it's either fall or another season just
denoted by the leaves that blow through
the title sequence the big red leaf
literally flows right through the oh and
you see a couple of different powers on
display with different characters there
are two brand-new younger-looking
characters that appear but they haven't
officially revealed who they are but I
have a pretty good theory about what's
going on and has a lot to do with their
journey of self-discovery and finding
out about where Elsa's powers actually
come from they're really mysterious
about the way they open the trailer with
Elsa looking very determined like she's
definitely going to cross whatever body
of water there is either it's an ocean
or just like a really giant river it's
hard to tell she's going somewhere else
using her powers but it's not quite
enough the whole idea I think being
because you see Anna by herself stuck a
couple different places trying to also
escape it seems like they get separated
at some point and they're gonna need
each other to help get out of whatever
situation they wind up in that was sort
of the theme of the first movie was her
learning to be comfortable with her
powers like being who she was meant to
be but also developing a deeper
relationship with her sister but
probably one of the most important
things comes from the official poster
and this one scene here of Anna looking
out her window with all these ice
crystals frozen in the air with a bunch
of different symbols on them look at
these ice crystals look at the different
colors they look like they denote
different elements or different seasons
because look at the four different
points of this ice crystal in the first
official poster it's these different
symbols so it's either denoting the
different elements or the different
seasons but also different
like Elsa has frost based powers the
first movie does nothing to explain
where they come from why she has them or
how they even work like she just kinda
has to figure that out on her own so I
don't think it's a coincidence that
you're seeing this new wind based power
with this new character here and I think
the new character isn't so much a new
character as a flashback because a lot
of people's first reaction was like wait
a minute is this onna and Christoph's
children it even though a couple of
years have gone by since the events of
the first film these kids are way too
old to be their kids I say look almost
exactly the same age is Anna and Elsa do
in present day the really important
thing though is that they look almost
identical to Anna and Elsa's parents
when maybe they were younger so a really
good chance that this is her parents
meeting for the first time and they use
the movie to explain where Elsa's powers
come from in this place where their
meeting is the location that you're
seeing them look at on this cliff face
here where most of the movie is probably
gonna take place what it seems like
happens is just like based on these
weird ice crystal formations is that
this scene is taking place in arendelle
some weird magical event happens or
something weird happens with Elsa's
powers they don't understand it they try
to find out it either the troll mage or
someone else gives them the information
that they need to travel to this other
new location to get the answers that
they seek and in doing so they also
discover a lot about their past because
for the most part these Disney movies
are all journeys of self-discovery of
one form or another
even though this is the sequel think
they will continue to explore themselves
and find out who they really are the
other really important thing you notice
in the trailer is is that anna has way
more action scenes that she did in the
first film that she's jumping across
this cliff face looks like she's trying
to save herself she draws this big sword
when it seems like somebody is coming up
on them so even though she got to do a
lot of cool stuff in the first film it
seems like this film is focusing on her
becoming a hero even more than she was
during the first film so the way they
cut some of these scenes with the other
flashback maybe characters and those
different powers also implies that maybe
Anna has powers too that they find out
about during the film think about it
like the Avatar cycle water wind fire
earth whatever the different elements
that are going to be using for the film
she might wind up having one of those
different abilities and if this winds up
being her mother be
they say the ELSA was born with her
powers so it implies they were passed
along biologically through their family
so even if this isn't their mother it
might be another one of their ancestors
from even further back if you remember
the first film they didn't really get
into the mechanics of her abilities or
anything like that they just said that
she had powers and she didn't know how
to control them and she was shutting
herself off and turning into something
of a super villain trying to push
everyone away but the only other person
confirmed that we know about in the
movie that had any kind of sense for
what was going on was that troll mystic
but he was mostly there just to bring
Anna back from the edge of death and
give Elsa that warning like be careful
this could happen someday they're just
gonna pushed her on her way like good
luck have fun with that born with the
powers of cashed born and they're
getting stronger you are lucky it wasn't
her heart the heart is not so easily
changed but the head can be persuaded do
what you must
I recommend we remove all magic even
memories of magic to be safe but don't
worry
I leave the fun she will be okay I have
powers
it's for the best listen to me answer
your power will only grow there is
beauty in it but also great danger you
must learn to control it fear will be
your enemy will protect her she can
learn to control I'm sure the other
really important line of dialogue in
that clip is when he says he's healing
honor bringing her back to consciousness
is that he's removing all magic and all
memory of magic as well implying that
onna had some kind of magic within her
that he took out or he blocked somehow
it's a really ambiguous comment and
little Elsa is like wait she won't
remember that I have powers but also I
think the twist is maybe that she won't
remember that she has powers the movie
doesn't really analyze Ana's character
that much when she's young is mostly
focused on their relationship and Elsa's
powers so we think big twist he was also
sort of putting this block on whatever
her powers might wind up being it might
be based on one of these other different
elements but like I said remember Disney
movie pretty standard journey of
self-discovery so it looks largely like
Elsa continuing to discover where her
powers come from but also in doing that
Anna winds up discovering a lot of new
things about herself so post all your
frozen to theories in the comments below
the other important thing to remember
this is the biggest year ever for Disney
so even though frozen one was like this
big box office powerhouse that was
frozen everywhere on YouTube back in
2013 and 2014 when the movie came out
but even though I think Avengers endgame
is probably gonna be Disney's biggest
film box office worldwide this year
don't forget that they're also releasing
Star Wars Episode nine which you know
regardless of how you feel about the
franchise is gonna make crazy money but
big surprise like they're doing all the
live-action remakes of their old
animated films I think that the Lion
King winds up being one of their biggest
box-office earners worldwide next to
Avengers endgame this is a snapshot of
their release calendar
movies on here that I'm not super
looking forward to our Dumbo just
because it doesn't look like it's gonna
be one of their stronger live-action
remakes don't know anything about this
penguins what it looks like a
documentary film so it can't really say
much about that in Artemis Fowl just
because the books are interesting but
the movie doesn't look super compelling
based on the footage we've seen so far
so let me know in the comments just
looking at this giant list of Disney
movies this year what do you think the
top three box-office earners are gonna
be for them six of these 10 films are
probably gonna do about a billion
dollars at the box office
each some of them close to two billion
dollars like Avengers endgame but we'll
talk about box office predictions for
Avengers endgame and Star Wars all that
stuff later this year there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that just dropped
in the past couple of days leave your
video requests in the comments below I
know I didn't do in Aladdin trailer but
so many people were hating on that that
I couldn't think of a good spin and it
seemed like people are a little more
interested in what's going on during
this hopefully you're not having too
many nightmares about Will Smith genie
but I do love some of the memes while
you wait for everything click here for a
brand new Captain Marvel and Avengers
endgame trailer video and click here to
rewatch that new Lion King trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]